hey 42 here explorers in archeologists
have uncovered some of the most
mysterious site markings and riddles
that our ancestors left upon the earth
but despite our best efforts many of
them remain mysteries to this day so
here's some of the most mysterious
mysteries ever found the Nazca lines are
a series of ancient geoglyphs in the
Nazca desert in southern Peru scholars
believe these mysterious markings were
created by the Nazca culture around 400
AD the designs range from simple lines
and geometric shapes to animals trees
and flowers the geoglyphs were created
by removing the reddish pebbles on the
surface to uncover the white ground
below the largest figures are over 200
metres across the Nazca lines have been
preserved for so long due to the extreme
dryness and lack of winds on this huge
plateau changes in weather are extremely
rare in this region and the area is
highly isolated which has enabled these
archaeological masterpieces to survive
for thousands of years if you think the
Nazca lines are impressive you will be
blown away by the sajama lines in
Bolivia similar to the Nazca lines as
sajama lines are to a set of gigantic
lines carved into the Earth's surface
what the difference is the sajama lines
completely dwarf any of a geoglyph on
earth they are roughly 15 times larger
than the Nazca lines the sajama lions
cover an area of roughly 20 mm 525
square kilometres and the largest are up
to 18 kilometers in length the most
mysterious thing about the sajama lines
is that they're nearly perfectly
straight which is an incredible feat
considering the lines primitive nature
and enormous length many believe the
lines were originally used by indigenous
people when they made sacred pilgrimage
images and where the lines intersected
used to be shrined and burial towers
when one thinks of ancient and
unexplainable landmarks in England
Stonehenge
might be the first that comes to mind
but there are many many more and the
mysterious white horse in offing ttan is
a peculiar one of that the white horse
is a 115 meter figure carved into a
hillside it was created by digging deep
trenches then filling them with white
chalk carbon dating on the chalk
suggests it was created in the late
bronze age around 700 BC beyond this
very little is known about the origins
of the horse including who built it and
why perhaps the most baffling gawky
illogical mystery of all is the
legendary emerald tablet because unlike
others nobody is sure if it still exists
where it came from who wrote it or even
what it looked like but researchers have
found transcriptions of the tablets
texts in 6th century Arabic books the
original text was in the ancient Syriac
language it was later translated to
Latin in the 12th century
then later into English by Sir Isaac
Newton who had a pawn shun for alchemy
the text is considered to be the single
most important document in the field of
alchemy because it supposedly contains
the secrets of the Philosopher's Stone a
substance able to transmute base metals
into gold in 1999 a Russian man by the
name of Vladimir crane of called a
professor at the Bosch keyer State
University in Russia named Alexander
shove you off because he had found a
strange slab buried in his backyard
little des crane of know that he had
stumbled upon one of the most baffling
archaeological discoveries on earth the
slab was so heavy that it took over a
week to unearth the stone slab was named
the - Cass stone but later became to be
known as the map of the Creator this
five feet tall slab weighs over a ton
this
don't contained representations of civil
engineering works Weir's irrigation
systems and powerful dams a group of
Russian and Chinese specialists in the
field of cartography physics mathematics
geology chemistry and the old Chinese
languages researched a slab and
identified it as an extremely detailed
relief map of the Ural region of Russia
such maps are used by the military today
scientists dated the map at over 120
million years old but specialists argue
that it would be impossible for an
ancient stone cutter to make such a
detailed map and that it has to have
been machined using extremely precise
cutting equipment which doesn't match up
with the map creation date some say that
the map of the Creator is therefore
proof of an advanced ancient
civilization that also had flight the
map continues to undergo scientific
testing and baffle scientists to this
day there is a legendary story of
unknown origin
that goes like this in 1938 an
archaeological expedition were sent to
investigate a secluded area of the Bane
Cara Allah on the border between China
and Tibet the group discovered a series
of caves high up in the mountains the
caves contained a large collection of
graves and the walls were decorated with
drawings of people with elongated heads
alongside images of the Sun Moon and
star when the archaeologists uncovered
the graves they found skeletons no more
than 3 feet tall with abnormally large
skulls inside the tombs were also a
collection of stone discs the discs were
12 inches in diameter and had a hole in
the center they also had a groove on the
surface that spiraled outwards from the
center they came to be known as The
Dropper stones naturally the stones were
sent to a variety of scholars for
investigation one of them
assume only of the Beijing Academy for
ancient studies found that the spiral
grooves were actually a line of
characters written in an unknown
language in 1962 - uh new announced that
he had managed to translate the language
according to the professor the stones
told the story of an alien spacecraft
that crashed in the bay in harsh an
region around 12,000 years ago the
occupants of the crash vessel were
aliens called groper The Dropper were
unable to repair the craft so they had
to adapt to conditions on earth however
the local ham tribesmen hunted them down
and killed them but many have challenged
this story and claimed that the drover
stones
never actually existed unfairly the
Shroud of Turin is a linen cloth that
bears the image of a man who appears to
have suffered physical trauma in a
manner consistent with the crucifixion
of Jesus Christ the Shroud is wrapped in
red silk and has been kept in a silver
chest in the Chapel of the Holy Shroud
in Turin Italy since 1578 the cloth
itself is actually a negative the true
image is only revealed when the image is
inverted and made black and white many
religious believers contend that the
shroud is the very cloth that was placed
on the body of Jesus Christ at the time
of his burial and that the imprinted
image on the cloth is the face of Jesus
himself
however radiocarbon dating performed on
the cloth argues that the relic was
actually woven between 1260 and 1390 AD
which is much later than the time of
Jesus but to this day nobody truly knows
where and what time period it came from
thanks for the view subscribe for more